i've also been dealing with um
since it's been since i've been you know
i've been i've always been obsessed with
like trolls
just on my instagram not the dolls yeah
yeah okay
yeah really yeah i was always obsessed
about how people
felt about me or um obsessed about
um if so and so got this thing
you know is successful that has nothing
to do with me i used to take everything
so personally
you know like oh [ __ ] uh you know some
[ __ ]
loser just said that you're not funny
and you should quit doing comedy and i
would lose sleep over it but i'm not
doing that [ __ ] no more
yeah since i've been out i'm not reading
com you know to say just little um
little things that i'm i'm gonna change
this time around bro you know
yeah do you get sensitive about stuff
like that no man it means a lot to me
that you say this kind of stuff man yeah
sometimes i feel like it like
i mean sometimes i feel like it's a
little hard maybe
probably to get to know guys like us you
know i feel like
sometimes i feel like it's hard to get
to know you sometimes like not in a bad
way
i love you you know you're like probably
the most lovable person to see
um you know i just
but then i think i recognize a lot of
the same things in myself like it's just
hard
to get to like i think we're just hard
to get to know sometimes
here's what i realized about bobby um he
uses his full
transparency and full blast honesty
to keep people at a distance from him
it's actually a defense mechanism to say
hey here's all of me so don't come to me
asking anything else
so there's no way for them to really
come close to him and ask him anything
anymore
yeah like the groceries are like in the
parking lot kind of a little bit
right kyla what just like you know what
i'm saying like um
no no no i'm not saying yeah it's like
i didn't know what that meant i was
trying really you know you're thinking
you never gonna go to the market yeah
and all of he's got all this stuff out
in the parking lot
yes exactly right yeah yeah he's like
yeah he just said that
he's like can't you see like i just said
you know everything here's everything
yeah
yeah i know it's so funny because i
think that like uh i'm not making this
about me but i i can notice as you say
that i've noticed
in myself sometimes like oh man it feels
like i share everything why do i not
have some of the connections that i feel
like i should have yeah that's exactly
what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
it's it's such a it's it's kind of like
a paradox right because you are
seemingly connected to so many people
who are influenced by your words
but don't have that true connection for
yourself in real life or day-to-day
yeah and it's really isolating and it
can really kind of wear on you over time
well when i was you know at the
institution stop calling it
the fbi holding cell bang was it a state
side where was it
arizona oh wow yeah so um one of the
therapists asked me just
because i had i had to list down who my
circle of
friends and loved ones are and
it's got to be people that i share with
that love me and that that know you know
that you have in an
intimate relationship even dudes right
um
kalila and my brother was on it that's
it and then he's like you don't have any
friends i go i have a lot of like um
acquaintances and comics that i like
like you
andrew i had lunch for the first time
with andrew yesterday
because when i got out i'm gonna try to
make an extra effort
to not get to know you as a comic
you know me but get to know you as a
dude you know because before all this
you were just a kid
you know what i mean you were born in
this world we're all the same
species we're connected you know but so
i mean different species huh different
different species but yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'm the dog brah yeah in that
but um
yeah so i'm gonna make it um here's
another thing that i'm gonna tr
i'm gonna make i'm thinking about not
even going to the comment stores often
hmm because when it's like a place that
brings out like the back
it brings me because there's a couple of
women
really there are regulars you know there
that
for some reason or another they'll
either say something
or behave in a way that is is not i'm
not
delusional about it it's obviously
directed at me wow
and whenever i go there i feel like [ __ ]
about myself
what are they saying specifically just
like belittling things if they do
belittling things
you know i mean and they do things that
um
will say stuff about me or to me
or i'll hear them on stage say stuff
about me
but that has everything to do with them
that has nothing it has nothing to do
with me but it's also um
you know i would have to say that my
relapse had a lot to do with hanging out
there in the wrong environments
really yeah wow and um
i also have to say this about the comedy
store um
that it's not the same you know it used
to be a place where
you could show up and if you got good
enough you get to go up
but now it's um names and that's it
and that's not what that place is
supposed to be yeah
it's supposed to be a college it's
supposed to be a school
where you learn to do it and um
i don't know i haven't made a complete
decision about it but that's just kind
of why that's why i haven't been around
you know i haven't been around because
um i need to figure out what i want to
do
you know um i even thought about not
doing this
for a bit when i was in the in in
institution
yeah i can feel that man this gets hard
this
podcasting gets hard sometimes man yeah
because you put you know
yeah well i start to become like there
are times like this yeah i didn't know
if i was like
myself if i was a character of myself if
i did like times i didn't know what was
going on
where like you know and you want to be
there for everybody because you feel
like the people that listen are there
for you but
but sometimes like i just didn't even
like i was just like
what am i even gonna say like i just
felt so just kind of
empty almost as a just not as a person
but just as
and it's in like a self-pity thing i
just felt like
man i'm on this train and there's no
real way
like people are going to be upset if i
don't do it just and a lot of the
stories if someone was in my head you
know like
because really people will be supportive
no matter what you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's what i i ultimately that's
why i'm going to continue to do it was
just that bro it's
it's it's i'm trying to
i know that this character that i do
isn't essentially who i am it's a little
bit of a mask
yeah right and um sometimes i would wear
this
mask out into the world right and then
when you don't take off the mask and see
who you really are you get
lost bro you don't know who you are
because i have masks where
where in if i go to an aaa meeting
you wear a mask yeah i almost did
everything in everything in every social
thing
and i think what i want to try to do and
maybe it's just because i just got out
of there
but i am bro
when you say that i love the fact you've
been institutionalized
man you need to be black bro go for two
more months and get black
that's what i want yeah